i saw something posted yesterday by
sportscenter that i have to share with
you see
tweet they shared by a man named chris
milton you may not know he's not a
celebrity he's a father two of his kids
appears one of them played for fresno
state the other one played for uga
georgia and he's a running back and
yesterday
chris milton the father posts a tweet
talking about a guy named justin harris
who plays for the opposing team
he plays for cincinnati and here's what
happened
there is so much power behind this tweet
oh my gosh it's so much power
the picture is going to be shown here on
the video while you're watching this
so cincinnati loses to georgia at the
peach bowl by three points
24 to 21 is the score
and justin harris is the only guy that
doesn't leave the field
he stands on the sideline watching
georgia celebrate them beating
cincinnati his team by only three points
oh my gosh and the dad says i see you
you're using this as pain what's the
point
look 2020 was probably an annoying year
for a lot of people
you know 2020 you know maybe you had a
great business here but maybe you had a
bad personal year
maybe had a great personal year but a
bad business year 2020 was filled with a
lot of different weird crazy stuff
i can think about it for myself when i
go back
one time back and i'll just give you a
couple of my public losses one of them
was humiliating
years ago publicly i lost humiliating in
and the the the folks who were handing
over the trophies
it was down to two people to be the mvp
they asked me to come on stage
and the other person to come on stage to
see who was going to get the trophy
they asked me to hand the trophy to the
winner because i got second place
and he got first place and everybody in
the arena was watching me
they said let's see how big david
handles it i whisper to the guy
congratulations you deserve this you
outworked me the last six months
i said but i want you to know something
here says what's that enjoy this moment
because it'll never happen to you ever
again
see that pain i stood on the stage and i
watched it
and i relished it and it produced the
kind of fire words cannot describe
what's crazy is so many of us waste that
opportunity
man so many of us waste that beautiful
opportunity of having that fire to go
out and prove a point
that you gotta fight that the world
needs to know about
i never understood when people are like
oh my gosh you lost oh shake it off go
to the bar
drink you know get hammered get over it
it's gonna be all right et cetera et
cetera
no no no use that pain very rarely do
you get a pain like that
when you do get it um don't get me wrong
i have empathy and sympathy because i
know how emotionally
painful it is in that moment because
another grown man
beats you and psychologically that can
torture a grown
man or a woman who lost to somebody else
not easy but only if
you're able to use that energy properly
and direct it in the right place oh let
me tell you
they better watch out for you if it's
used properly unfortunately a lot of
people when they lose they blame the
other person the other person cheated
the other person did this the other
person did that if i only did this if i
only had that
if i only had this because we need
alibis
but the few crazy competitors
that chris milton the father caught
you realize for a father to catch
something like that of another play
justin harris doing it
you realize what kind of values and
principles that father's injecting into
his kids from fresno state and uga i
hope he watches this video because he's
a great example to others
on how to raise tough kids i don't even
know this man but it just shows you
that mindset to say you lost
take it how does it feel what do you
want to do about it do you want to
experience a pain
like this again unfortunately today's
world says
you lost take medication drink
do this do that because it's very
painful to go through a loss
losses suck
they're horrible we're all going to have
them
some personal some business some family
some health some relationships some
friendship
some public some private we're all gonna
have them
no one leaves this planet not being
humiliated or embarrassed
none of us do but many leave this planet
blaming someone else rather than taking
responsibility and doing their best to
use that pain to come out and say
hey you may have knocked me out but i'm
gonna tell you here
i'm gonna come out here and do something
about it there was a man named chuck
webner they did a video about a movie
about him titled chuck i believe
it's the guy that went against ali 15
rounds and he
knocked him out one time he dropped him
one time
and sly made a story about it called
rocky that the world has watched
this guy didn't fight didn't give up he
had a dog fight in him
that a guy like sylvester strong was
inspired by his story
there's two people in that fight that
you respect one is ali
greatest of all time the other one is
chuck webner guy wouldn't give up
doesn't mean you're going to win all the
time doesn't mean even if you
internalize the pain you just got to
come back with a fight with an effort
with a certain level of focus and
sacrifice and determination that you
never put up before
if it matters to you and i'm hoping
today's video
for the right person is going to do a
lot for you
for the right person it'll do a lot for
you and if you're watching this and
you're saying well i kind of want to go
out there and do something about this
it's a video i did can't recommend this
video enough times because this is my
mindset of what happened to me
how to reach your full potential if
you've never watched it
click or even watch it and outside of
that
i wish you your family
everybody you know nothing but the
happiest
of 2021 challenges you overcome
and experiences that you only fantasize
about
have a great week everybody take care
[Music]
bye